I heard this album was right down to the
wire you guys were adding and making it
so great right up to it so come on right
we were just making making Nickelback
great again oh well you were you were
really pouring your hearts into it like
right up to sir
I like be political like it's like a lab
where we're like you know we're just
fine-tuning like we're like it's like a
lab where we look at the watch oh my god
we gotta get this thing done we gotta
get this thing finished it's like a
panic to finish it it was a bit of it
like we had some press that we needed to
do so we left like at the eleventh hour
and we flew out of LA and we went to New
York and we were doing then we had to do
this thing
for live nation and then then we came
back then it was like we're mixing songs
in New York in an RV
yeah front of the vent because it was a
small venue dad like up trailer we're
like I listen make sure the songs sound
going to like this is a terrible idea
idea actually fixed it so when you think
about the album how would you describe
it to everybody I on air Oh Carla so I
think that the I think this album is a
little bit more back to back to our
roots you know it's a little more rock
and roll and that's a good thing you
know it's uh and we ventured out on the
last half we did it we've been we've
been trying different things and you
know kind of mess around with you know
with we like to do anything we can get
away with with you I am Erin and but it
at this one we were like in Willets
let's get a little selfish let's let's
just let's go have a little fun and not
worry so much about if we're pleasing
everybody else let's make sure that
we're pleasing ourselves first and and
we did and we're really happy with it
well it seems like your fans I mean
they're dedicated to you no matter where
you go we considered is love your sound
and they love you know where you're
going is that ever a concern when you're
creating an album do you think about
them or is it completely just thinking
about what you guys want to do you do
but once again we have to be happy first
yeah you know and then we just kind of
cross our fingers and hope that they're
going to enjoy it
half as much as we enjoy it so I think
you get to the point um I mean it gonna
add some flows
we're yeah I mean it's nice to have
things that fans like mm-hmm
that people enjoy but it you start you
can get too far one way or the other but
it's nice I like this time where it's
like instead of like giving them giving
people what they like sometimes it's
good to show them what they like yeah
what they may like that's the kind of
thing that I think that's felt like when
we make yourself what's your definition
of success at this point I mean you guys
are tremendously successful you've done
so well you fans all around the world we
like you here at e2 Canada we think
you're kind of great but what is it for
you
but what is it for you that says well
you know what we got this this was good
we did we did well on it I think our
definition of success is when we stop
being kind of green Aditi and we become
just absolutely fabulous
we are your way look Riley it's no good
I can't you feel like to that side but I
feel you're trying I do I think
sustaining you know and maintaining like
just being able to to keep doing this
you know and we've been saying we've
been saying this for many albums now but
it's true we're we're really fortunate
we're really lucky you know we started
it in a garage planned you know our
instruments and and look at each other
going but it'd be great if we could play
in front of a thousand people see you
still remember those days you you've got
not far away for you no god no that's
those are fond memories perspective is
is absolutely everything that I think in
anything you do here we've got lots of
respect
yeah continue to get it every day